[Musique]
pour recevoir les enfants
je sais que vous êtes tous très sage ce
soir car vous attendez le père noël mot
sur ton le père noir un long gros
farceur tu sais bien que le père noël ne
vient que chez les petits enfants mais
je suis tout petit patron je suis très
[Musique]
inégaux prends ton échelle et descend
voir tes amis bureau
popopopop ou bo bo bo je
vais dans la cheminée mais c'est plat et
moi mais pas dans d'autres
mais je trouve plus qu'un certain émoi
les trouve pas de tout le soulier
bonsoir oh je vois que vous préparez vos
chaussures pour le père n'aurait jamais
mais pas les plus grands
c'est terrible j'ai plus qu'un seul
souliers blancs et moi j'ai pas de te
souli un long du calme quoique en show
si tu ne te prendre de papier du tout la
journée tous les retrouverait des
chaussures qu'ils avaient rangé ses plus
mais chez sur
[Musique]
le bord pop bronner
tiens regarde ces petits vernis noir
sont razi son
mais cela dont la cheminée
[Musique]
sens propre mais bon
non non je le trouve pas
regard nicollin mais je suis encore plus
elles sont bien plus petit aura moins de
jouer
nous sont pas là non plus alors et ses
souliers cornichons je les trouve pas le
dis tu crois que le père noël va quand
même venu
je ne suis pas un génie dit je veux
mettre mes chaussettes à la place mais
je vais les laver avant c'est une lave
elles ne seront pas serge cornut dans la
région j'aimais comme ça
nico leurs coffres au maire ça y est je
mets mes chaussettes dans la cheminée
images mais même décembre at il m'a dit
ravi sa technique je suis sûr que le
père noël va vous apporter des pas de
beaux cadeaux il est en jeu sauf et vous
souhaite une belle soirée donor à demain
annonce enfin monument chéri donne l
amith très bien nos dollars
levant haut
[Musique]
où
en route patron ce soir ce putt et je
souhaite à tous nos petits amis de
passer un joyeux noël et à tous nos
grands amis aussi joyeux noël
dogues
[Musique]